so confusing that hipsters have started
co-opting southern culture I feel like
we're gonna crack a rare old cosplay
party oh don't say co-op - well they're
gonna think we want to start a bait farm
coalition could use I really need some
fried okra Marik so can we please just
like make this work worried everyone in
here is just like a barista talladega
you ready to order yes ma'am oh you
don't use gendered pronouns in this
restaurant okay well I heard the e all
have the best fried chicken so I'll take
a two-piece dark with some mashed
potatoes and gravy okay we don't have
gravy and we only serve white meat
that's why it's all white people in here
excuse me cuz if the bland message light
is fine and I'll just take the cheese
grits instead okay regular regular what
vegan grits
that's just driest court it would want
to eat that people dress like an
Americana album about soybean subsidies
yeah track one white meat got me drier
than white man Mariah
hilarious this is ridiculous you guys
have vegan options all over the menu
there's a deer head on the wall his name
is William we're honoring I like your
trucker hat what do you haul apparently
cognitive dissonance this is just an
outfit look drew your dad's an outfit
you can wear it to your next hillbilly
hoedown party I hope y'all are digging
the reclaimed barnwood because there's
poop in barns we're eating in a poop
lodge that's not true there's no poo in
here that lady has a mullet Oh what the
hell's going on out here I'm up to my
ass in grease it's hotter than a Randy
Bobcats butthole back there what's the
deal customers are upset they think that
light meat chicken is dry is that right
I'll take care of this we got chicken
problem and the Earnhardt posters
crooked oh my god living breathing Yelp
review coming in here pitching a fit for
he's even had a bite to eat yet I swear
to Conway Twitty you make me want when
you're hotter than grease yes peace your
honey we're in from Boone North Cal
Waukee Boone North Carolina you mean
your parents had
vacation house outside of Asheville
right no I mean like my uncle still on
the run for breeding illegal reptiles
from Boone North Carolina and you made
this menu yes we're here to duck Watson
died what what percentage Cherokee are
you 1/16 on my mama's side 1/8 on my
daddy's side vinegar or ketchup vice
barbecue mo when greeting a fellow
southerners I'm scared I know how much
sugar goes in sweet pea till it's sweet
enough
Dolly Parton Oh golly you know let's the
preachers coming over then we got to
pretend like it's Jesus for a minute but
when you were punished as a kid where
would your parents hit you home school
church anywhere with sticks really
that's a phenomenal answer mm-hmm just a
few more questions Willie gets all the
credit because he started it but
Weyland's the best outlaw Skynyrd's
plane went down in galesburg mississippi
you can fry anything if the grease is
hot enough and Doc Watson died on May 29
2012 smartass dude why are you making
vegan grits as I sell animate that bad
and doctor told me I got the
pre-diabetes the catfish don't you mom
and him I said hey okay they that's
sweet mullet
so my fix Dale I like this place
you